en vrai qu'en ce moment le bon soir
bonsoir c'est marrant avec votre nom
j'ai toujours pris vous étiez un
philosophes du xviiie siècle en fait
c'est drôle les noms de famille parce
qu'à part philosophe au châtelain pour y
faire quoi avec ce nom j'imagine un
footballeur chapelle comte sponville
zidane passe à dugarry qui passe sa
concubine qui m'a ça marche pas alors
andré ampère nous serons tous les deux
nous parlerons philosophie nous
essaierons de dire des trucs
intelligents c'est pas fatiguant dire
tout le temps des trucs intelligents
vous n'auriez pas envie de dire un truc
qu'on a pas
c'est une excellente question je vous
remercie de l'avoir posée et voilà c'est
con l'émission s'appelle 7
alors vrai qu'on se videra bonsoir vous
êtes ici ce soir dans le cadre de notre
série philosophe en access prime time
après bernard henri lévy michel onfray
andré glucksmann michel serres luc ferry
et benjamin castaldi je sais j'ai
complètement craqué la semaine dernière
vous êtes comme tout ce que je viens de
citer un philosophe médiatique c'est à
dire à la fois bénéficiaire est victime
de vos passages à la radio et la
télévision
bénéficiaires parce que vos livres sont
lus victimes parce que c'est paradoxal
de réduire 40 ans de travail et 5000
pages de philosophie à quelques heures
de télévision non c'est vrai que
l'expression de philosophes médiatiques
je n'entends toujours comme péjorative
c'est le fleuve qu'on voit à la télé
parce qu'on oublie que par ailleurs il
écrit des livres etc parce qu'il écrit
des livres qu'on le voit à la télévision
alors victime aussi parce que la télé
par peur du zapping 1 l'animateur vous
laisse pas déroulé votre raisonnement et
c'est difficile de philosopher
brièvement oui ça s'est il faut dire que
c'est de pire en pire parce que quand
j'ai commencé et a publié et donc à
faire un peu de télévision c'était du
temps de deux pivots ou de michel polac
on pouvait parler cinq dix minutes vont
être interrompues aujourd'hui c'est
devenu pratiquement impossible pourtant
les gens ont besoin de philosophie pour
apprendre à aimer la vie pas aimer le
bonheur parce que mais le bonheur c'est
la portée de tout le monde mais aimer la
vie la vie heureuse ou malheureuse on
confond trop souvent la philosophie avec
le développement personnel ou services
de thérapie facile qui prétendent vous
apporter le bonheur comme ça à portée de
main la vraie sagesse c'est d'aimer la
vie y compris quand il est difficile
d'aimer la vie heureuse ou malheureuse
sage ou non or sache personne ne l'ait
complètement si vous ne il faut donc
accepter la par an soit dans goise de
folie de deux malheurs parfois mais pour
essayer en effet de vivre plus
heureusement si bien que le bonheur et
le but mais c'est la vérité qui est le
chemin et la philosophie essaye de se
rapprocher du bonheur avec un peu plus
de vérité
alors
andré vous êtes né en 1952 à paris en
france pas très joyeuse auprès d'une
mère snob dépressive et suicidaire elle
a fait plusieurs tentatives de suicide
pendant votre enfance votre maman
jusqu'à en mourir vous aviez 30 ans à ce
moment la tourelle faut dire aussi que
tu es une femme extrêmement et main oui
c'est une très bonne mère que j'aime et
que j'aime passionnément mais c'est vrai
qu'elle était malheureuse qu'elle a fait
en effet plusieurs tentatives de suicide
et qu'elle a fini par réussir la
dernière mais là c'était déjà un adulte
ça a joué un rôle important dans ma vie
évidemment mais y compris
philosophiquement parce que j'avais le
sentiment que ces moments de joie était
toujours un peu factice et qu'en
revanche elle était parfaitement vrai
dans le malheur c'est bien que j'avais
fini par associer le malheur et la
vérité et c'est en lisant les
philosophes et d'aborder plusieurs grecs
que j'ai compris que non c'était une
illusion qu'on peut avoir un vrai
bonheur un bonheur vrai que c'est
l'illusion en vérité qui rend malheureux
mais vous savez quand j'ai publié mon
premier livre 2010 car j'ai reçu
quelques semaines après la lettre d'un
psychanalyste qui me disait qu'il était
d'accord avec moi pour penser qu'il
fallait essayer de se guérir de se
libérer de l'espérance parce que me
disait-il je constate dans mon cabinet
que l'espoir est la principale cause de
suicide mais parce qu'on se tue surtout
par déception mais c'est vrai alors
votre maire était aimante votre père pas
du tout jamais un mot affectueux vous
dites le premier compliment qu'il m'a
fait c'est quand j'ai intégré normale
sup où il avait 20 ans
il appartenait à cette génération
d'hommes pour lesquels montrait de
l'amour il un prix à ses enfants ça ne
se faisait pas
voilà les pères étaient beaucoup moins
aimant il ya 50 ans aujourd'hui et lui
étaient très caractéristique de ce type
d'homme de l'époque donc votre merde a
quitté quand il s'est remarié il devenu
beaucoup plus sympa quand même j'ai vu
un autre homme
transfiguré par l'amour et par le
bonheur et du coup ça m'a aidé à mieux
comprendre ce qui s'était passé avant ce
qu'il était et est à comprendre qu'au
fond cet homme n'était bien sûr pas
méchant simplement il était malheureux
enfant vous vous rêvez écrivain jusqu'à
la terminale où vous découvrez la
philosophie et là vous êtes fasciné
quand j'ai découvert la philosophie ça
m'a tellement passionné que l'amour de
la littérature et surtout de la fiction
s'est éloigné je me suis dit au fond à
quoi bon inventer des histoires quand la
vie réelle est tellement passionnant
c'est bien j'ai gardé la vocation
d'écrivain nous lui d'écrire des romans
j'ai décidé d'écrire de la philosophie
alors de la même façon la passion
politique de de mai 68 va emporter votre
foi chrétienne
d'abord dieu cesse de vous intéresser
puis finalement vu cessé d'y croire je
suis donc devenu athée vers l'âge de 18
ans tu es je le suis resté alors
l'athéisme devient pour vous une
évidence si vous avez une phrase
formidable dieu revient à expliquer
quelque chose qu'on ne comprend pas par
quelque chose qu'on comprend encore
moins et pourquoi spinoza disait que la
religion et l'asile de l'ignorance et je
crois que sur ce point il a raison vous
dites si cela ne dépendait que de moi il
y avait belle lurette que dieu
existerait je préférerais que jésus soit
ressuscité je préférerai retrouver ma
petite fille qui est morte bb oui c'est
à dire que au contraire de mon ami
michel onfray je n'ai aucune haine de la
religion je comprends très bien que les
gens souhaitent qu'il existe un dieu
aimant puissant plein de justice et de
miséricorde et en effet ça serait le
mieux il était justement parce que ça
correspond tellement à nos désirs les
plus forts qu'il y a lieu de suspecter
que nous avons inventé cette croyance
que pour satisfaire nos désirs ce qui
fait de la religion une illusion au sens
que fredonnent à ce mot quand frau
explique qu'une illusion c'est une
croyance dérivés des désirs humains il
m'arrive de dire que dieu est trop beau
pour être vrai qu'en effet c'est en
principale d'être athée vous êtes laïque
mais très inspiré des sagesses
orientales
zazen s'asseoir respirer réduire la vie
à sa plus simple expression oui je suis
laïc bien sûr at t mais je me définis
comme athée fidèle à tes parce que je ne
crois pas en dieu bien sûr mais fidèle
parce que je reste attaché par toutes
les fibres de mon être un certain nombre
de valeurs morales culturelles
spirituelles qui sont nés le plus
souvent dans les grandes religions et
spécialement pour nous dans la tradition
judéo chrétienne ou moi jésus n'est pas
dieu ni fils de dieu c'est un homme mais
un homme évidemment exceptionnel dont
dont l'image continue de de m'éclairer
en quelque chose et puis il ya en effet
les spiritualités orientales alors que
j'ai découverte beaucoup plus tard bien
sûr mais c'est vrai que le bouddhisme
spécialement et plus encore sa variante
chinoise le tchad et japonaises lezennes
font partie pour moi des spiritualités
les plus fortes les plus profondes et
qu'en effet il m'arrive de pratiquer la
méditation assise ce qu'on appelle le
makhzen et je crois que c'est très
important pour un philosophe qui
travaille avec le mental avec des mots
avec des concepts de prendre parfois le
temps de s'asseoir de respirer de rester
silencieux et attentifs fait ça dans
quel environnement je le fais chez moi
bien sûr mais surtout quand je suis à la
campagne dans une maison que j'ai en
basse normandie où je passe quatre mois
par an est là tous les matins au réveil
je pratique ça cette méditation assise
silencieuse sans objet quand je suis à
paris c'est plus difficile parce que
j'ai une vie comme tout le monde un peu
plus agitée ça prend ça s'apprend en se
pratique en serait ce que disait
aristote c'est en forgeant qu'on devient
forgeron c'est lui qui est bien c'est en
méditant quand on devient méditatif
ouais
donc on peut méditer là un peu si vous
voulez mais ça va peut-être assez mal
passé à l'antenne mais on
on peut essayer c'est pas sûr mais à une
posture apprendre gens parce que quand
j'avais 18 ans 0 non non moi je ne sais
pas non
on est assis le dos droit c'est très
important c'est une position à la fois
de confort et de stabilité on respire on
ferme les yeux les yeux sont mi clos un
emprunt en principe est on est attentif
à sa respiration voilà le point de
départ c'est ça être assez strictement
immobile et être attentif à sa
respiration en principe on ne le fait
pas devant les caméras mais après tout
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus